- I'm scared.
I'm super scared.
I'm scared because I know
exactly what happens
this month every year.
Every year.
For the rest of time or actually
not the rest of time hopefully
this will end soon but I'm
scared, I'm scared because
I know that there are so many of
you that graduate this month and
have no fucking idea
what you want to do.
And that's okay.
Most people don't.
We should not be
stressed about that.
I'm actually not
scared about that.
I'm scared that you don't
realize that you're entering the
greatest five-year
window of your life.
If you are 22 years old and
graduating from college,
shit if you're 22 years old and
not graduating from college,
if you are 22 years old you are
entering, first of all, some of
the greatest years of your life,
A, but B, this is the moment,
watch this video twice.
If momma's watching this,
send this to your daughter Sally
right now because you have to
understand this next five-year
window is when you don't
go practical and safe.
This is not the time to get
the job mom wanted you to.
This is not the time to try to
maximize as much money so you
can buy a fat whip.
This is a time to realize that
you have a five-year window and
it's three for some it's
eight for others but this is a
five-year window for you to
attack the life that you want to
win not because it's "The
Secret" or 'cause the world's so
Zen 'cause it's fucking
hard as shit out there.
As a matter of fact, I'm
probably more scared of than
your naïveté to hard it is.
Class is easy.
What you been doing for
the last 16 years is easy.
It's a fucking bullshit game.
It's structured, it's easy.
The world, this thing.
This thing is hard.
However that contradicts what
I'm going to tell you right now
which is this is the best and
easiest five years of your life
because this is when you need
to attack what you love and
what you want to.
Here's why.
You don't have all the baggage.
You may have college loans,
respect it's hard as shit.
You may have the
expectations of your parents.
Mentally hard, fake hard.
You may have a lot of other
things but this is exactly when
you can live with four
roommates in a basement
and eat fucking fast food.
Do you understand?
This is not when
the baby's there.
Some of you have babies.
This is not when you've
been married and you promised.
This is not when the
world has sucked out all
your dreams and hopes yet.
You've still got this window and
yet so many of you are so hungry
for short-term gains.
Maximizing the job that paid you
$3000 more but it's not as fun
but you want the $3000.
For what?
For a new iPhone?
You get to live life one time
and this is the time right now to
understand what's actually
happening and actually map your
behavior to something
that will impact you for
the next 80 years.
So promise me, promise me all
you youngsters that are watching
this right now in the fucking
comments, 'cause I'll jump in
and talk to you, promise me that
you understand that the land
grab of happiness
starts right now.
That you don't have to
worry about getting that job.
What you should do is
go and travel and learn.
Go and start that business
that you've always wanted.
Hook up with those three
teammates and start
that band you've always wanted.
This is the time massively
risk, massively risk oriented.
I know that this is what is was
a grow up and go see the world
but guess what, the world isn't
what mommy and daddy told you.
The world is exactly going to
be what it's going to be with or
without the way you
thought is gonna be.
A ton go shit is
going to change.
The world changes
every god damn day.
Right now what you need to
recognize is you can afford to.
And not all of you I'm sure.
Some of you will leave a
comment and say I've got a loan.
I get it, respect.
But that loan is going to be
there whether you go and try to
and build something for yourself
or not one way or the other.
And by the way, you
can work at night.
This is when you put in the 18
hours a day to make your life
that you want happen.
And again 'cause I'm scared I
can hear myself fucking talking
I'm not saying it's "The
Secret," its practicality.
When you are in your early 20s
this is when you can grind at
your highest levels 'cause
there isn't all the fucking
baggage that comes
across with life.
It's harder for the 42-year-olds
that are watching right now to
listen to this advice.
You just can't wake up tomorrow
and be like "Let's go," 'cause
little Sally has
soccer fucking practice.
And because you got 1 million
other things that are
holding you down.
But boy, if you're lucky enough
to be graduating today with not
a fucking idea of what you're
going to do with your future
nobody's ever been
luckier than you.
Please recognize it.